[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump has promised a news
conference Wednesday I'll believe it
when I see it he has every reason to
cancel it or simply ignore his promise
the trick worked with the news
conference about his wife's reported
immigration irregularities the trick
worked with the news conference he
scheduled for December 15th to address
his potential business conflicts of
interest the trick worked when he
promised for last Tuesday or Wednesday
revelations about Russia's hacking of
the election of course Trump has broken
his promise it's a trump promise but
this news conference is designed as and
here is my favorite word again chaff to
deflect from the now for confirmation
hearings Trump at his Senate monkey
Mitch McConnell has scheduled for the
same day including the confirmation of a
nominee who had not yet been vetted by
the ethics office
DeVos at education including the
confirmation of the man who defines the
corporate globalism Trump himself
specifically denounced as recently as
December first Secretary of State
nominee Rex Tillerson who's actually a
resident of the nation of Exxon to
deflect from these real problems
Tillerson is like the John Houseman and
Ned Beatty characters from the movies
rollerball and Network Trump has to say
something outrageous to start a new
flimsy controversy at a news conference
to lie about somebody to dig up a new
scapegoat to find a way to attack
Hillary Clinton or NBC or me or you but
Trump's handlers have a problem
he is increasingly self-destructive
statements about Russia and hacking and
the Putin WikiLeaks scandal have
suggested Trump is losing what little
self-control he still has and that there
is every reason to suppose that instead
of providing chaff to protect Tillerson
and the rest of this gang of pirates he
has nominated he will instead reveal
something impeachable about himself
again like he did in his last news
conference
if only the country had fully understood
it at the time there is a specific
reason Trump has not held a news
conference since the 27th of July last
year it is because on that day he
inadvertently eliminated the need to
prove that his campaign knew in advance
that Russia was hacking American
for the specific purpose of putting him
in as its puppet in the White House
after that July 27th news conference
proof of that was no longer needed we
instead had solicitation of an identical
crime that was the day he asked Russia
to hack American computers for him
personally he was asked about Russia and
the hacking that had already been done
and instead he answered about Russia and
the hacking he would like to see and if
it is Russia which is probably not
nobody knows who it is but if it is
Russia it's really bad for a different
reason because it shows how little
respect they have for our country when
they would hack into a major party and
get everything but it would be
interesting to see I will tell you this
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the thirty thousand emails
that are missing I think you will
probably be rewarded mightily by our
press let's see if that happens and in
the same news conference the follow-up
question for my pal Katy tur no less
that's up to the president let the
president talk him look here's the
problem here's the problem Katie Katie
here's the problem very simple he has no
respect
she then references his call to have
them released 30,000 Hillary Clinton
emails he resumes quote well they
probably had them I'd like to have them
released
she is incredulous does that not give
you pause he resumes because even then
he could not leave it alone no gives me
no pause if they haven't they have them
we might as well fine hey you know what
gives me more pause that a person in our
government crooked Hillary Clinton
here's what gives me what be quiet I
know you want to you know save her that
a person in our government Katie would
delete or get rid of 33,000 emails that
gives me a big problem after she gets a
subpoena she gets subpoenaed and she
gets rid of 33,000 emails that gives me
a problem now if Russia or China or any
other country has those emails I mean to
be honest with you I'd love to see him
this in retrospect was an inducement to
a foreign power to enact espionage
against citizens of the United States of
America they have not let him hold a
news conference since if Trump really
shows up and he has asked anything about
anything except Russia except what he
said about Russia if the thing is wasted
by question after question about Meryl
Streep then every reporter who speaks at
this news conference should leave the
profession if journalism still exists
under Trump because not only is the
subject of Trump's disloyalty to this
country essential to our continued
existence as a nation but there's no
work involved either the damned
questions are just lying there in the
quotes from the last news conference
resist peace